Hey,
what's going on?
It's bill burn.
It's the Monday morning podcast for Monday,
March 30th March 30th to everybody in like a lamb out like a lion.
Remember I told you guys that I was going to go to the fucking gym?
You remember I said that?
What?
I say?
Fuck you called it.
Remember that you remember?
Oh my God.
Stacy,
your members.
MMM,
well Billy freckles fucked up this week.
I went back to New York City.
New York City is fucking an evil,
twisted place for me as far as I just have too many friends,
too many comrades,
too many Booz bag drinking buddies.
I fucking drank like Dean fucking Martin all fucking week.
I went to the gym once,
I played pickup hockey twice.
So that's kind of like doing some audio.
Uh,
I guess I walked to the subway,
went up and down the stairs.
Other than that,
other than that,
it was an absolute,
it was a shit show I put on display.
I put on a display,
a fucking drinking this past week.
Um,
I'm surprised that like,
you know,
maker's mark is not sending me like some sort of trophy with their bottle on top
of it.
All right.
Oh Jesus.
Oh,
what did I,
what the fuck was I doing?
You know what?
You know what New York,
it's weird.
It's like you walk around so it's good you know about staying in shape.
But like the shit's open all fucking night.
Not Everything by the way.
Cause I remember back in the day when I was a kid and they were like,
it's the city that never sleeps.
It's open 24 hours.
I used to think that meant like banks,
hardware stores,
like everything was open.
It isn't all right.
Everything closes at a normal fucking time.
Like everything else except for the places where you can really get in trouble,
like bars,
um,
and fucking late night places to eat.
Just every fucking dumb ass thing that you could possibly do to wake up the next
morning looking like you're in your first trimester.
Um,
that's what I did coming home.
Fucking hammered.
Right.
That's another thing too,
because his taxis all over the place.
You don't have to even consider,
hey,
wait a minute,
I have to drive.
You know,
I don't have to drive.
I don't have to do anything.
I have like fucking 100,000 designated drivers out there.
My friend,
my friend waiting to take me home
and because I'm a white man,
even if I'm just going to walk home,
they're still pulling over.
Hey my friend,
my friend.
Right?
So kind of privilege.
I have you in the blue eyed devil,
right?
I can't even walk off the fucking pumps.
That's a form of terrorism right there.
When you see a white guy that you know needs to walk off the booze and you
fucking pull over and I'm not even asking for a ride and you still try to get me
to get new cab because you hate my country's foreign policy right there.
You're like my friend my did to my cup.
Yeah,
you have a heart attack when you're 50.
Okay.
God is great.
Right?
How fucking hack he was that,
that was me doing a version of every standup comics.
Um,
I guess Indian accent.
Well,
what do you expect?
I got to do one of these every fucking week.
I've got a workshop.
Some shit.
Give me some hacky shit on here.
What the fuck are you doing?
Oh,
sit in your desk with your little pen and pencil set that your mom and dad got
you.
Cause he was so proud of you.
Oh,
we're still proud of you.
He's a penitential sitting this stapler.
You know what?
Fuck your office supplies.
What do you think about that?
Fuck you look at your desk.
Tell me right now.
You're not sitting at your desk and you just don't have the urge to fucking put
your fucking arm down on one side of it.
Yes.
Just clear it right off like Denzel Washington when he's in a movie and the
dialogue isn't up to his acting level,
so he's got to start slapping cups of water out of people's hands just to make
it seem compelling.
Huh?
You know what's fucked up about Denzel in Samuel Jackson could shop though two
of the great fucking actors of of whatever.
What did you say last 2030 years?
Right.
They keep sticking him in those like the blank movies,
right?
The negotiator,
the fucking freelancer,
the architect,
whatever the fuck.
It's always the something.
Okay,
Geez,
can you get him a fucking script?
Well,
you know what,
can you guys stop stealing movies?
So the $50 million budget movie comes back,
you conch instead of everything being $100 million robots,
you know,
with umbilical cords,
the aliens,
whatever the fuck goes on in there,
right?
It's either that or talk in apes or what do you have?
You got it.
You got an independent movie for fucking 800 grand,
which you know is going to be a bunch of awkward fucking nerds,
you know,
with their fucking glasses.
They've fucking hoodies.
Anyways.
Okay.
Anyway,
so what do you,
what are you going to do?
What do you let,
let's,
let's just plow it.
I didn't know what the fuck I'm saying here.
All I'm telling you is that,
you know,
last week you have to me talking all this shit that I should go,
go step on the scale and see what the damages I have to do that after this
podcast.
I swear to God,
if I'm back up over one 80,
um,
you might,
you know,
if you listen,
if you listen intently,
you might hear me.
You might hear me weeping.
Oh Man,
I'm fucking off the rails.
But it starts today.
No,
it doesn't start today.
It doesn't start today.
You know,
cause I was out of town and uh,
you know,
my wife's been super busy and uh,
there's nothing in the fridge.
My truck is getting fixed.
I don't have a vehicle.
And you know what I got up so you don't have upstairs in the fridge.
I have a weak old lunch meat and I have some fucking guacamole because my wife
saves takeout.
She just sticks it in there and she,
I mean,
every fucking little thing,
it's insane.
Okay.
She's like a hoarder of,
of of leftovers.
Like little fucking every packet of sauce.
Anytime we ordered Sushi,
she sticks all those fucking packets and they like got,
you know,
God forbid some day of fucking macro falls through our ceiling.
We got to eat the whole thing.
We'll have enough soy sauce.
Right.
Those things.
Old Chopsticks,
little tins of sour cream,
you know all those little things that are,
or
okay,
fucking Balsamic vinaigrette.
And then once every,
every three months,
I gotta be the bad guy.
I got to be the guy that goes in there.
Yeah.
Listen,
everybody,
you know,
like I'm kicking some bum out that was supposed to get an apartment.
Come on guys.
You gotta go.
All right.
Get up off the couch.
You tell Guacamole you're out.
I feel as though you can turn our shit
right.
That's what I have upstairs.
I have a container of Brown guacamole.
I already threw it out.
You know what I mean?
I'm fucked.
I got one can of dog food.
I don't know what she did this weekend.
You know?
What do you mean?
But you can't give him shit.
You give them shit and then what?
They get mad at you.
They get mad at you when they didn't do the broad job of keeping the fucking
refrigerator stocked.
That is a woman's job.
Go Fuck Yourself.
I don't care if you have hair under your armpits or not.
That's a fucking woman's job.
The same way.
My job is,
I got to take the fucking trash out to the curb.
There's certain things that were and always will be a man or a woman job around
the fucking house,
and I just feel,
you know,
keeping the fucking refrigerator stocked.
You know,
your hero for your inspiration,
for the man in your life.
I don't think that that's asking too fucking much,
is it?
I don't think it is
Jesus Christ.
Whatever.
I hit a fucking bowl of cinnamon likes this morning.
What am I fucking eight years old?
Those are my options.
You know,
I would have had the oatmeal,
but there's no banana.
I've got to have a banana with the fucking oatmeal.
You know,
you know this about me.
Oh Jesus Christ.
I mean,
why?
Why,
why even?
Why even get involved in the fucking argument?
Bill,
how long have you been with,
you know,
better don't take the bait.
Just fucking sit there and be like,
oh,
always say nothing in the fridge.
Oh,
that's great.
Thank you sweetheart.
You have a good day.
Bye Bye.
Hey Cleo,
you want us?
You want to split a fucking kid,
a dog food.
You must remember this.
A kiss is just a case.
Um,
I came home anyways.
I want to,
first of all,
before I do any more babbling here,
it'll in the podcast.
I want to everybody over at Madison Square Garden this week for asking me to
come over and do the garden of dreams,
the garden of dreams,
um,
benefit this week.
I could not have had a better time.
I went to a rangers game.
I went to a Celtics game.
You know,
we played pickup hockey.
I've listened to the Thursday podcast.
He played pickup hockey at Madison Square Garden.
You know,
unbelievable.
The hardest thing I had when I was there at Madison Square Garden,
skating on the ice,
the only thing harder than trying to keep my heart rate my heart,
literally from jumping out of my chest.
The only thing harder was trying to find a championship banner hanging from the
rafters.
They got all kinds of banners up there.
They've got banners up there for like division championships.
I mean,
it's a sad thing.
It's such a wonderful arena.
Uh,
come on as a Boston fan.
You know,
I had to break a little bit of balls,
but it was,
uh,
it was tremendous and,
um,
we couldn't have had a better time and I have the puffy booze face to,
uh,
to prove it.
I had a,
I had a great fucking time.
Um,
and now I'm back and I believe me when I told you this morning that I rolled out
of bed,
hey,
let me tell you,
I rolled out of bed,
you know,
I'll tell you last week I had a rough one.
Um,
anyways,
so like I,
uh,
I come home last night and,
I got home late and a back out here in La and uh,
me and the wife watched that Scientology movie on,
um,
on Hbo and you definitely should check it out.
All right.
But if you,
if you don't sit down before you even watch the first second of it,
and Sadie is self,
that they could literally do the exact same documentary on every fucking
religion on this planet,
um,
then you probably shouldn't watch it.
Cause you're going to be one of those people that watches the Scientology video
and be like,
dude,
these people fucked.
It's all fucked.
It's everything that they're doing was,
I can't speak for our religion.
My religion did.
Time's a zillion as far as I know,
Scientology for as abusive as they're,
they're claiming that they've been,
they never killed anybody.
You know,
they didn't go around fucking children.
Like my fucking organization.
I don't have one rock to rock.
I don't have one rock to throw.
But,
um,
I will tell you,
man,
they,
uh,
it was,
it was just more of the same.
I watched it more like not just looking at it like this is Scientology.
This is what the fuck it is.
I looked at it more like a,
just like human beings,
and this is what happens when somebody is allowed to slide into the Jesus'
position.
Mohammed,
whatever you want to call it.
When they slide in there,
who's twos?
The Jewish guy.
Who's that?
Jesus was there some guy named,
I can't test to hack.
You have see some guy named Marie Abraham.
Is that,
that guy?
I don't fucking know.
I have no idea.
They all sound the same to me.
There was nothing,
nothing was going on.
And then this guy showed up,
he did a bunch of grade shit and now he's the guy.
Give us your money but boo booboo and is it okay if uh,
she blows me.
Um,
anyways,
plowing ahead here.
Um,
you should definitely a highly record
meant
that you check that out and um,
I dunno,
I felt bad for Tom Cruise.
They made him look like a soccer,
you know what I mean?
Especially,
you know,
anytime,
you slow down the video and you put Weirdo music in there,
you're going to make somebody look bad.
And um,
yeah,
I don't know the fuck.
I mean when I sit there and think of the shit that I bought into,
donate it to a Goddamn booth until some fucking Weirdo.
All the bad things I did that week.
What is that all about?
Huh?
Bless me.
Flatly.
Five CNG and he had engaging my last fucking confession.
I jerked off.
I beat up my brother,
I fucking stoles.
It's just like,
okay
in,
this guy's just sitting in there.
What the fuck are you doing in there?
Your Weirdo?
Yeah.
Okay.
Listen to it through all this shit.
I got to go there and confess to you.
You can't.
Why can't I just go right,
go direct route.
What am I going to connect and fucking Dallas talking to you?
Why can't I just fucking go straight there?
No direct flight to God,
their buddy.
What are you doing in there?
Hey,
what's going on in the other side of the wall there?
What are you doing?
Your Weirdo.
Ah,
you filming this shit case.
I want to run for office someday.
I'll fucking call you off for banging a kid.
You've got all this weird footage on me.
I don't know.
All of it is fucking weird.
I think everyone,
I think everybody should just walk away from all of,
that's what I,
that would be my suggestion.
You don't have to,
but if it works for you,
fine.
Um,
unless you become a country.
Oh Jesus.
But why do you try to make points?
Why did they never go anywhere?
Did they go anywhere?
I don't think they do.
Um,
so anyways,
so what did I do this week?
Jesus
running out of shit to say already.
It's already 15 minutes in.
I think I got to fucking read some ads just to keep it going.
So I,
uh,
my,
I told you guys my truck,
uh,
um,
I dunno,
I cooked the valves on it,
man.
I fucking so pissed at myself.
So they're uh,
they're rebuilding the whole thing.
The whole engine brand new.
I can reuse unleaded gas at,
won't fuck the thing up.
And uh,
it should be done sometime this week.
I actually,
uh,
adding air conditioning and I'm getting the power steering and um,
that's just going to be my fucking daily driver.
And I kept the three on the tree because it was just too fucking cool.
Skye was building is going to like do it.
We can fuck it.
Fuck you can get this thing cruising at about a hundred miles an hour.
It's just like,
I don't want to do that.
It's too fucking cold shifted on the column.
You know,
I think it's too fucking cool to,
uh,
to get rid of that.
So,
um,
basically
I'm going to have a bad ass fucking truck here in a couple of days,
which would be nice.
Cause then maybe I could fucking,
you know,
so clear when that I could go down the street and I can maybe put something in
the refrigerator and maybe I could eat something.
Oh,
let me tell you,
my wife,
she get off.
She doesn't,
I've got a wife,
you know,
she does have,
she does a stock the frigerator.
Why just the other day?
Um,
anyways,
uh,
let's,
let's read a little bit of a advertising for the week.
I swear to God,
I know I must've saw something ahead of them.
It's,
you know what,
I just had a fucking tremendous week.
I don't know what to tell you.
I enjoyed myself all week.
I did the,
um,
I did the benefit for a first,
he's brother-in-law and I actually had a great time up there,
levity live,
which is a fucking unbelievable comedy club by the way.
I had always heard that it was one of the best in the country and it definitely
lived up to it.
And um,
I'm trying to,
uh,
figure out a way where I can get back there at some point.
Terry town played the Tarrytown musical,
which was the last second gig.
And um,
it was fun,
man.
I'm back.
You know,
we got the,
we got the cartoons all recorded,
we got all the records it done and uh,
now the drawing the shit and we just,
I don't know,
my schedule is totally opened up now and I can get back to being a standup comic
and I can't fucking wait.
I can't wait for the southern tour and I'll build these fucking cigar face still
is not at a cigar.
All right.
A mob coming up on like five weeks from everyone.
I told you guys I was gonna be that guy who smoked a cigar once a week.
That's what I was trying to do.
I was trying to cut down my cigar smoking to a near 52 cigars a year,
which is still way too much.
So have to fucking January and February I was already up to 12 cigars,
eight weeks,
12 cigars.
I'm off the fucking rails already.
So I didn't smoke anything in March.
Um,
we're already up to the 12th week,
so now I feel like I'm even,
but um,
okay.
No,
I told version and those guys that I wasn't going to,
um,
I wasn't going to uh,
smoke until the,
uh,
the bus tour and then I was going to smoke,
but I gotta be honest with you,
I might not even smoke on that one.
I might just wait until my birthday because I figured my birthday's in June and
then what if I'm still on 12 cigars now I'm down to like two a month,
which seems way more fucking acceptable then.
Uh,
I dunno,
I had my fun with,
if it didn't give you a mouse throat and fucking God knows what else,
other kind of tongue cancer,
I would,
uh,
I would probably smoke for a week.
That's how much I enjoy it.
But I just,
I dunno,
I dunno.
Seen Leonard Nimoy die and saying he regretted smoking and he was like 83,
84,
85 years old and yet didn't you still think of fuck if I didn't do that with
Keith?
He knows people,
young people.
You look at,
you look 82 rod be fucking happy with 80.
Yeah.
Until you fucking 80 and you're staring death in the face and you're like,
fuck,
you know,
I wish I just drank waters and fucking was a vegetarian or whatever the fuck you
thinking.
So the fact that he was still thinking,
he would think if you smoked and you still made it to 83,
84,
85,
whatever the fuck it was,
8,345,
um,
you'd be like,
yeah,
whatever.
I had a good run.
That's what you think until you,
that person laying in the bed,
right where in that smock with your ass hanging out of it and you're like,
wow,
this is it.
This is it.
I'm not going to get to watch anymore hoop anymore hockey.
I'm not going to get to walk down the street,
listen to the birds Chirp and this is fucking it.
It's over.
And it's over sooner than it should have been because they fucking said I can't
get it out in my head.
So I don't know.
I think I'm done.
Okay.
No,
who's kidding?
Who?
I'm not done,
but I mean,
I am a
okay.
I,
I dunno.
I don't want to pick it back up again because I,
I,
you know what the fuck happens,
right?
You're trying to eat right just like I was.
I go to New York and I have one slice of pizza and all of a sudden I'm meeting
like some fucking
okay
fat guy on prom night who didn't have a date because it was pathetic.
I'm ashamed of myself.
You guys want any fat shamed myself?
Go walking to the bathroom mirror.
Huh?
You want to hear this?
I'm going to do it right now.
I'm going to show you what fat shaming is all about right here.
This is what it is,
right?
All right,
let's see if,
let's see the tears.
You're up crazy shit.
Oh,
we'll do it.
I gotta stop.
You know,
I just realized I have to stop because my neighbors will think I'm actually
yelling at my wife.
So that's it.
Fortunately I got my pull up by my dip station out in the garage.
I'll do that.
Oh,
my body literally just reacted when I said down.
You don't want to kill it will move the pizza.
So you that I got the grease in me right now.
I've got the crack.
I'm on the crack right now.
That's what I did in a food way.
You know,
I was craving salads.
I was crazy.
Fucking healthy food.
One slice of pizza and a couple of fucking boot.
You know,
we went off the rails was right after we skated.
Right?
Yeah.
MMM.
You know,
fucking exhausted.
Totally wiped out.
And uh,
we were gonna we were going to the US,
right?
We were going to the rangers kings game that night.
So we went to a bar and ordered an appetizer and I ordered this fucking beer.
There's nothing better after you played hockey and you really feel like you
earned the fact that you could actually sit down and have a beer because you
burn so many calories and I'm easily the best beer I've had in like six months
was fucking delicious.
And I remember sitting there and I was eating shit already that wasn't healthy
and this switch just went
like in my body.
I literally felt it like,
oh well are we doing this?
Huh?
Is it like,
you know,
it was like substitute teacher like is is the Douche gone now we can go back to
Busan and eating greasy fucking food.
I bought ice cream this week.
I haven't had fucking ice cracking and wants that.
We even fucking had ice cream,
stupid ass fucking New York walking home,
hammered stumble into a deli.
Oh they get a bacon,
egg and cheese on a roll.
How are you doing?
Hey,
I ain't fucking,
next thing you know,
I got that.
I bought Fritos.
And then I bought a pint of fucking cookies and cream ice cream.
Right.
What am I on my period fucking go back to the thing.
Wolf it down.
I went easy on the ice cream,
but it had just was fucking over.
Okay.
Sitting there reading like I'm at fucking seventh grade and cafeteria.
All right,
let's,
um,
okay,
let's get on with the,
Oh,
by the way,
somebody gave me something when,
uh,
when I was playing hockey one day I've never heard of this is called junk bomb.
Okay.
Bomb like,
like a roll on.
And it's literally deodorant for your balls.
Is that not the funniest fucking thing ever?
And the guy's giving it to me and it's going well,
you know,
he's like,
if you know,
if you played hockey,
you don't have time to take a shower.
You just put this on.
Your boss
was like,
what the fuck?
Are you serious?
I swear to God the is a real thing.
So I'm laughing and I'm like,
well shit,
if you got Sherry's berries,
you know,
if we got fucking one wipe Charlies,
how do you not have junk?
Biomeds I got to have junk bomb on on the podcasts.
There's little,
if any of those guys that listening,
it would fit right in.
Hey guys,
don't have time to take a shower.
Okay,
Jesus.
Judah,
if you don't want,
if you're fucking balls as smelling to the point that you smell them,
I mean Jesus and you don't have fucking time to take a shower.
I gotta make time.
Hey honey,
I'm going to be a little late.
Trust me,
you're gonna thank me later.
All right,
here we go.
Bob has everybody help him say it.
Our Bond Bombas B o m.
B.
A.
S.
Bravo,
Oscar,
Mike Bravo,
Alpha Sierra.
Chances are if you have feet,
you wear socks and face it.
Socks haven't changed since they were invented.
They fall down,
they were out.
And there's always that toe scene that never seems in the right place.
Our new sponsor Bombas Bombas a book on buzz has changed all that,
but ambos dedicated two years to engineering socks.
Two years.
Some nerds sat in a fucking factory trying to make a better sock.
Okay.
Can you give him the decency of listening to this whole advertisement here?
Walked in the Goddamn closet,
right?
They spent two years in these stinks.
Engineering socks that stay up lasts forever and feel amazing on your feet.
They last forever.
I have a pair of Bombus.
No,
I don't personalize your experience with Bombus example.
I find myself watching them over and over so I can wear them again.
I need to get more.
All this is what I'm supposed to say.
Uh,
to know what I'm talking about.
You really need to try a pair for yourself,
but listen,
but on buzz,
does it stop with your comfort with every pair of socks?
Bomba sells.
A pair is donated to someone in need because socks is,
it turns out are the number one requested item at a homeless shelter.
Isn't that nice?
That's actually really nice.
Oh,
Billy softy right now and for unlimited time.
But on buzz is offering my listeners 20% off their first order and free
shipping.
Just go to bombas.com/ [inaudible] all lowercase,
B o m B a s.com/ [inaudible] B u r r.
Dot now for 20% off the most comfortable socks on the planet and a pair for
someone in need.
Go to [inaudible] dot com slash burr that's bom B a s.com/burr.
Actually,
you know what?
They did send me a pair.
I was just on the road.
I haven't gotten them yet,
so I can't wait to put them on and wiggle my toes in them and I'll let you know
how great they are.
And I'll tell you if they feel as good as me.
Yeah,
these me undies,
no more sweaty balls.
Boop,
boop,
boop.
Me undies,
me,
Andy's where I'm in a bathroom stall.
You Ain't come down to your fucking ankles.
Next thing you know what?
Gay Senator Blows Ya.
You gotta get some fucking me on these.
Your balls will feel really good.
Oh yeah.
Robin up down your tank.
We rarely made it.
Yeah,
get you sell
so fucking me on these.
All right,
undies,
90% 90% that's the percent of your life that you're in your underwear,
right?
What's your a Gigolo was some napalm went off.
You're running down the street naked with your skin hanging off your back and
underwear.
It gets old fast.
You know that feeling of putting on old saggy underwear,
you know that feeling right?
Hang it down.
It's not even touching your balls.
And every once in a while,
you know,
you jump up to see what's on top of the fridge and you saggy underway,
hits your balls and it's so weird.
You feel like someone slapped your nuts from behind.
You turn around,
there's no one there.
You don't want to do that.
You get all paranoid Nixon,
you know,
he start talking to yourself.
You lose your job and then you know what happens next.
You lose your underwear's.
All right?
You need to know the feeling of great fitting underwear that is two times softer
than cotton.
Some poor bastard.
It had to sit in a lab is they rubbed fucking underwear.
And one of his face cheeks in the cotton on the other,
you know,
and they kept slapping them into the face till he said,
all right,
it's two times softer.
I thought if I just said,
yeah,
it is softer.
I thought that that would be enough for you guys to release me.
Um,
you need to know about me on these.com.
Me undies is the most comfortable underwear you will ever wear.
And it's insane how good they make you feel when you're walking around with half
a fucking stiffy.
They fit perfectly.
They don't ride up on you and they literally pull moisture gross.
Oh,
away from your skin.
See a stay.
Cool.
I have mine on right now and I'm floating.
No I don't.
Um,
they have cool styles for both men and the fucking lady.
No more sweaty twats and all.
And they all look great.
Check out the photos for yourself than me.
UNDIES dotcom.
This quality would typically retail for two times the me undies price,
but for some reason they want to make less money.
No retail middlemen means more savings to you.
Here.
I will make it easy for you.
Go to [inaudible] dot com slash burn and get 20% off your first order and free
shipping.
All right.
Have your balls high and tight for the rest of the week.
Save even more.
When you buy a pack of them,
they guarantee you're going to be happy with them
or your first pair is free.
All right,
there we go.
Two and two.
This week everybody will get to draft kings and a legal zoom lays it legal zoom.
Yeah,
we'll get to that later.
[inaudible] to good.
The bad at pepper pepper.
Oh,
actually,
you know what?
Hang on a second.
Last week.
Here's,
here's something for bombers.
The sock advertiser,
this is a Andrew Theremin was sent me this,
the uh,
the man behind the curtain on this podcast.
He said last week you said maybe you should send me a pair.
Well,
they actually sent you a pair of bill and I put my review with them at the top
of the emails last week.
They're great socks.
They had no problem with the read,
but they ask that you relay my experience.
If you're not going to try them.
Well,
where the fuck is it?
Okay,
I'll wear them.
You know what?
Send me a fucking
pair.
I'll wear,
uh,
wear the fucking things.
This is what my life is.
I am a sock tester.
20 something years in comedy.
You know,
you think people
fuck with my job.
They didn't want to use my feet.
Um,
anyways,
we're at 29 minutes in.
I'll tell you a couple more bullshit stories.
Then we'll get into the questions for the week when that be nice.
Wouldn't that be a nice thing?
And what's on in the world?
What about that fucking jerk off that flies the fucking plane into the Alps.
I mean,
Jake,
I you kit,
you're depressed to that fucking level.
It's one of the worst God damn things.
I,
I've,
what the fuck would I bring that up?
You know what I mean?
Fuck that one.
That was a couple of,
there was a couple of eight hotel.
It was a couple of aviation thinks this week.
You know,
I'm up in Canada.
Okay.
They came into fucking low I guess.
And they,
they,
they don't really have some sort of tower Assam Shit.
Jesus Christ,
I fly all the fucking time.
Man.
That shit is absolutely terrifying.
Um,
I just can't imagine what kind of level of fucking depression you have.
I get it.
You know,
it's bad enough you'd go out and to harm yourself.
You'd never want to see them.
You go and you take out all those other goddamn people,
man.
It's just the worst fucking story ever.
And there's,
you know what?
And there's absolutely no comedy in it.
And now here we sit.
I'll tell you what,
there was no comedy in.
Oh is it segue?
Somebody sent me this picture.
This is the saddest fucking pictures I ever seen.
It was of a seal that was born like a redhead in all the entire seal community
just rejected this seal.
And they take this fucking picture of this seal and it's all by itself and
looking way off in the distance or all the other seals said it just wants to
hang out and play with,
you know,
and learn how to fucking fish and not get eaten by a shark or whatever.
And they just totally leave it alone.
It's unbelievable.
This is just like we're fucking animals.
Same thing.
Same fucking treatment.
I got on the God damn playground.
It's happening to a fucking seal.
I saw that seal and you,
what kills me is the people that like take pictures of it and don't interfere in
nature.
It's like,
would it kill you to take that thing home with you?
Just get one of those above ground pools.
You know what the fucking thing hang up a couple times a year.
It comes in for the Superbowl.
You know,
come up on the couch there.
Redheaded seal.
I feel your pain.
I have empathy.
Who Do your gut?
Don't fucking say Seattle.
You've got to be back outside.
Um,
one of the satisfying pictures I've ever seen,
I can't get it out of my eye.
It just,
it fucking killed me.
Fucking kill me.
It's unreal.
Yeah.
The human things that I can laugh at,
but you show me a fucking sad animal and it crushes me.
It's why I stopped watching the discovery channel like a decade ago.
I don't watch any fucking nature shows because I know how it's going to start.
It's going to start with me being all wide eyed and excited and enjoying the
program.
And then there's the inevitable and then man and fucked everything up.
I'll tell you right now,
if you work for a fucking corporation,
I mean can you,
can you slowly work your way out of not working for one?
Is it even possible?
I was watching.
Did you guys see that clip?
I retweeted it.
Somebody sent it to me of a,
you know,
they're doing that fracking out in a Nebraska.
Okay.
Horizontal drilling,
whatever the fuck it is.
And however they go about it,
people are claiming,
okay,
that it,
that it pollutes the fucking drinking water.
So this farmer comes in,
he talks about all the great drinking water that they have in Nebraska,
and then he pours in the goop.
He's sitting there at this town meeting and he's allowed to talk.
So we asked these constant work for the fracking companies today,
would you,
would you drink this water?
I just want you to ask me that.
Would you drink this water?
And then the fucking chairman of the board goes,
you're not allowed to ask them questions.
Okay.
Oh,
you're allowed to do was come up and make comments.
It's like when the,
what the fuck are we doing here?
Okay,
well does this,
you supposed to let me just say what I have to say and then I run along and then
you fucking let these guys destroy the drinking water in this state because you
don't make any fucking money as a politician.
Unfuck it just,
I dunno,
I watched that thing and
I got to commend that that that Nebraska guy for fucking not flipping out.
Oh you're not.
I'm just allowed to make comments where here's my comment.
At least go and dump it over their fucking heads.
What kind of fucking people are involved in a goddamn business like that then
ends up polluting the fucking drinking water and you,
so thinking about all you give a fuck is your next quarter profits,
like where is that all going to go?
Like where,
where does,
what's the end game in that you just keep having a more profitable thing then
there's no more clean drinking water and then what?
You've made enough money to have the machine to fucking have.
Make sure you have clean drinking water and everybody else fucking dies and you
somehow justify it is you lie in your giant fucking bed.
Oh,
right here.
It's so fucking depressing.
I mean,
that's why I sit around.
I watch sports,
I watch people build cars.
Those are like the two fucking areas that I can kind of stay in where I can kind
of a,
I dunno.
Okay.
Nobody says anything racist.
Nobody pollutes drinking water and it's not a redheaded seal who just wants to
be part of the fucking group.
Just sitting there looking all sad.
The thing was a fucking baby.
She had a baby man and they just sit.
They fight.
You know what?
Fuck seals.
But you know what?
Fuck all those fucking seals.
I'm glad they get eaten by those God damn sharks.
I used to give a shit about seals.
Now they know that they're fucking racist.
Bunch
of cons.
You know what it is too.
I bet there was some seals down there that didn't give a fuck.
They just went along with the group and sat there silently.
Right?
Is the one bully seal a Jesus bill?
Is this what the seals are?
Your fucking childhood.
All right.
All right,
let's get to the,
uh,
let's get to the goddamn questions for the week.
That always kills me when they tell you they can do that.
Just don't interfere with nature and you're just going to sit there and look at
that sad shit.
All right.
If you are,
by the way,
if you want to follow us on Twitter here,
um,
the podcasts Twitter handle is at the Mlm podcast and the yawning here and the
podcast email is bill at the [inaudible] podcast.com.
Once again,
that number is bill@themmpodcast.com.
All right.
That's if you want to send an email.
You know,
I just realized too is my internet sucks in this house.
I don't have a car right now.
I got my crazy pit bull so I can't even drive down to the local fucking coffee
shop to use their Internet to upload this fucking thing.
So hopefully,
uh,
what,
what the fuck are you going to do?
What if it's fucking way?
It's like,
what am I going to do?
All right.
Oh,
by the way,
um,
I got a big guest this week.
Hold.
Let me tell you.
Got a big guest for the Thursday.
Uh,
just checking in with your fucking podcast,
whatever the hell I'm calling it,
but it's actually going to go down on Friday,
but you'll be happy.
You will be happy when you hear the guests.
They got a big guest.
He is the star of my favorite new show.
Do you know what the show is?
A post apocalyptic show.
Former SNL cast member.
Action Hero.
You know who he is?
He's going to be on this Friday.
All right,
here we go.
That's called a teaser.
Um,
warehouse listeners.
Bill.
I'm 19 and I work in a warehouse part time.
Oh my God.
And the most fun job you'll ever fucking have.
I was 19 when I worked in a warehouse and I worked there part time,
fucking greatest.
He said,
I've introduced your podcast to the guys there and we listen to it regularly.
You've come full circle.
Okay.
Oh is that,
oh,
that was just the thing.
Well that's cool.
What are you guys been doing?
Huh?
Fucking off there in the warehouse and all of a sudden somebody with a tie comes
on,
you're like,
well,
who's that?
He started acting like you're fucking moving boxes around.
Okay.
I haven't really missed that fucking job.
You know,
the way I traveled,
you know,
back in the day when I worked in a warehouse,
my commute to work was a little over a mile.
Like we lived in like the last neighborhood before there was this industrial
park.
Um,
like if I wrote a bike's bicycle to work,
it probably take me 15 minutes.
And there was weeks where I would put like,
you know,
I'd go to work and then I would drive home and then I would work out,
listen to appetite for destruction.
I'd lift weights throughout that whole fucking album.
And then I jump on a bike,
uh,
by my bicycle and I do like a fucking 10 mile bike ride.
And then by then,
you know,
it was like seven o'clock or so,
and the Bruins and Celtics or wherever it had a game,
and I was in for the night and I would do that right up until Friday.
So Monday,
Tuesday,
Wednesday,
Thursday,
I probably put like 12 miles on my truck.
I had this 83 Ford ranger that I bought them and we had 19,000,
317 miles.
And I remember I own that fucking thing for forever.
I drove that truck for fucking 10 years,
um,
even after it started rusting out from all the new England winters,
but I remember like I put on so few,
few miles until I became a comedian and then it went through the roof.
And then I remember,
um,
the engine shit,
the bed.
And,
um,
there was a critical moment in my life.
I had a day job and everyone was saying I should go out and go buy a new car.
And I'm,
uh,
I just kept thinking,
if I buy a new car,
then I got payments,
then I need to have a job.
So I said fuck it.
And I just hadn't put a new engine in it.
I told you this story.
I remember that girl.
A woman at work was like,
that was stupid.
That was stupid.
Really?
I don't have a fucking car payment.
Hey,
guess what?
I'm quitting my day job to move to New York City.
See Ya.
You know,
have fun with your Ultima.
Um,
anyways.
Sorry.
All right.
Fat Shaming.
Counter argument.
Uh,
alright,
dear Billy ginger balls.
This guy's going to count a fat shaming by fucking trashing me.
Okay?
He sounds like an open guy.
All right.
I love your podcast and I listen each week.
I'm a Chubby guy who was working hard to lose some of my ex excess weight.
I'm down from two 40 to two 15.
There you go.
Woo.
Dude,
that's a big change to 40 to two 15.
That is fucking,
come on bill.
Do the math.
That's 25 pounds.
Okay?
It's 125 miles of capillaries out the fucking window.
However,
I would argue that despite the name you've given to your discussions,
you aren't fat shaming anyone and that's a good thing.
You are more of a coach than a true fat shamer.
Dude,
I know what I'm doing.
I'm not going to depress you.
I'm going to get you in that mindset,
okay?
You know you're better than that.
When you were a kid,
you weighed that crap,
you to that dream.
Okay,
I know how to do it.
I know how to give you shit while I fuck it up.
Lift you.
I'm a fat.
Shamer is a person who looks at an old way.
Person says you're worthless.
You are of a f u r a failed person and you can't do anything to fix yourself.
Who the fuck says that?
You said I like that dude in that drum and movie.
Yeah,
you fucking piece of shit.
So why I couldn't,
I couldn't get into whiplash.
Okay.
After like the first 20 minutes of that guy getting screamed at the fact that he
didn't have the self esteem to get up and walk out.
It's just loud.
It's like,
all right now I don't give a fuck.
It was like gone girl.
You know,
if you haven't seen it yet,
block your ears for the next fucking 15 seconds.
Okay,
I'm going to talk about it in three,
two,
one the fact that after he found out what the fuck she did and then she comes
back and then Tyler Perry's like,
you motherfuckers are crazy and walks out and like he stays with her at that
point.
It's like,
Hey,
you know,
I don't give a shit.
I don't give a shit if she fucking kills the Ben Affleck character right now
because that Ben Affleck character does not seem to give a fuck.
That's how I felt with like whiplash.
It's like,
all right.
You know,
if you don't have to get yelled at to play drums,
well,
but if you feel that you do when you want to sit there,
then yeah,
then you're a fucking jackass.
See,
that's what I do.
I'm empowering you,
Huh?
To get off the couch and you know,
he'd get off the couch,
you know,
just don't get off the couch.
You gotta lift your fucking legs.
Do a little role lead back into the couch.
Adapt we Gowe right.
That should be your next goal.
When you get up off the couch,
you just get up off the couch.
That's a milestone.
That's a marker right there.
Well,
you don't have to do the one g two g and then fucking get all the way up.
Literally
sounding like you're doing a squat like that last one of the set.
Hey,
when you get up off the couch waking the babies scare in the family dog,
you can't be like that.
He said anyways.
To me,
you're a coach who says you're healthy.
You can fix this,
but it won't be easy,
but it's worth it.
Absolutely.
Abso-Fucking-Lutely I really think that so much of a staying in shape is,
um,
is being conscious
of craving something that you know is going to make you feel like shit
afterwards and hate yourself in the morning when your belly sticking out.
Even more.
Like last night I'm coming home from the airport and I am on the crack.
All right.
Pizza,
ice cream,
potato chips,
beer,
whiskey.
The whole fucking week and I'm coming home.
What do you think I'm craving?
You think I'm craving a fucking salad?
No.
What is the thing I need the most of fucking giant salad that will go into me.
It'll be nutrition with a bunch of fucking cancer is poison on every leaf that I
try to rinse off,
but I'm doing the best I can or whatever.
But what we'll do,
we'll level me off chemically and I don't even have a fucking science
background,
but I know it's going to,
it's like,
you know,
it's like you're in a ship that's rocking.
You're getting into to,
to,
to stable water,
calm seas,
and you can make an intelligent choice.
All right,
so last night what I should have done is I knew it,
I was saying,
you should order.
I literally have heartburn.
I should go.
You should order a fucking salad.
That's what you should do.
And it was conscious enough to think that.
And I still went inside and I went and I made myself walk waffles with fucking
butter and Syrup and all that.
And you know,
and this morning I wake up and you know,
because they ate that last night,
I'm looking at oatmeal and then I'm looking at cinnamon life and what do I do?
More heroin,
more heroin,
and I go with that.
So,
um,
but at least I'm aware of it's the right now I have to critically right now,
like what I decide to eat right now for lunch can literally informed the next
three months of decisions if,
if I'm not careful and I can put on 10 to 15 pounds just because last night I
didn't order a fucking salad.
And then where are you then you fucking back at the gym because you not because
you want to be,
because you have to be,
and you've got that big fucking lump of shit.
You gotta,
you gotta take off from your middle,
like you eat your way in and eat your way out of the gym.
So I have to today make a fucking smart choice.
MMM.
And I gotta get,
I gotta get back on the stick.
So a congratulations to you going from to 40 down to two 15 whatever you're
doing.
MMM.
Hope it works.
And it hope you're reading up on nutrition and I hope you're not doing one of
those fad diets,
you know,
any of those beach diets or any of those,
young catnap carbs.
I've never haven't bred again.
You know,
that type of shit.
Cause you know,
eventually one day you just going to sit down with an entire,
you can have one loaf of bread in one hand and a stick of butter and the other
with some ice cream waiting in the fridge if you fucking do that to yourself.
Um,
I don't know.
I've actually,
I've actually thought about just writing down
like,
cause everybody,
oh this is my cheat day.
You like your cheat day can literally like,
that'd be like a drug addict.
Like all right,
I'm not going to do drugs,
but on Sunday I'm going to do heroin.
And then the next day it's right back to clean living.
MMM.
Like your cheat day can literally throw you off chemically to the point.
The next day you're eating fucking waffles like an asshole.
Um,
but maybe if you write it down,
you know that this is what you're going to have.
And then you write a short paragraph,
hey,
you know,
hey cunt face,
listen,
why don't you eat this for breakfast rather than fucking up for the next three
weeks and putting on 20 pounds.
You know,
once you listening to when you order something healthy,
we two three bites into it.
Like this calm comes over you like,
ah,
like nutrition.
You know what I mean?
I read this great thing one time of why you can eat so much Chinese food or why
he can eat a whole fucking bag of Doritos,
even though you've eaten enough to be full,
but your body is still craving nutrition and there's not an ounce of nutrition
in that shit.
So despite the fact that you took a whole fucking bag of it and threw it down,
you God damn pie hall,
your body's immediately,
it's still crate craving nutrients or whatever the fuck it is.
Whatever the proper terminology is for it.
MMM.
Which is also why if you eat actually,
you know,
fruits and vegetables you get,
you get full.
MMM.
Arts.
You know what I get?
I get up.
I have to make sure I eat well.
I really do.
This isn't even about you guys fucking about me.
I'm being selfish right now.
Let's get back to more a skip back to more fucking emails here for the week.
Uh,
naming food places.
All right.
Hey Bill,
you recently asked about places to eat as your tour of the great lower half of
this country is about to begin.
I've been a longtime listener
and I get you to no name policy when it comes to telling stories that may be
incriminating or name dropping.
But you said you didn't want to say the names of the restaurants out of fear
that it would ruin the place by creating some type of mom scene.
And the food will go down hill and it'll get franchises,
something bill.
Come on now.
You're basically repaying them for their hard work.
Possibly generations of hard work by walking out,
by walking out in disavowing all knowledge of the place,
the way the u s government handled Vietnam.
Jesus or more specifically John Rambo and Rambo to on behalf of all these
establishments.
I like to thank you for being
uh,
for helping protect them from increased revenue and supporting a healthy,
healthy sense of pride in a life's work.
Also,
I'd like to thank you on behalf of people like myself who occasionally travel,
who would much rather just walk around and play guessing games about where to
eat.
It's much more fun playing.
We'll this suck roulette we'd read.
We'd much rather trust Yelp reviews that are probably real people and not paid
reviewers or family members hyping some shit.
Establishment circuit 2011.
A real man of the people,
this bill burr get a Makita.
All the cities Saifai Billy Skywalker.
You know what dude?
You had me until you fucking glorified all the cuts on Yelp.
Yeah.
Yelp,
I swear to God is like if you want to see what happens to somebody when they get
their own TV show and how most people's egos go through the fucking roof,
all you have to do was just looking at,
look at the common man on Yelp.
No,
everything was good in aiding late to sugar packets.
These fucking animals,
they'd be seen the average jerk off that walks down the fucking street breathing
through their mouth wearing socks and fucking flip flops.
Those fucking assholes who obviously have no power in their life.
They go on Yelp and they're fucking ego goes off the fucking rails.
Here's something.
What do you think happened back in the day when people went to town before Yelp,
and I don't mean the 1950s I'm about the fucking 1980s the 1990s you know what?
You struck up a conversation with the locals.
He said,
hey,
I'm in town.
I'm having a really good time.
I'd like to get some food.
You know of a good place.
There's nothing to local wants to do more than the point you to the place that
is the shit in their town.
And you go in there and you sit down and you have a fucking unbelievable meal.
And then you go back and you tell your friends,
hey,
if you ever go there,
you gotta go to this spot.
The fact that it has to blow up like some fucking boy band and now nobody can
get a goddamn seat.
Nick,
give me a fucking break.
I stand by what I'm doing.
And you know why I get applause when I say that I went to a country recently.
I said,
this place is so fucking beautiful that when I go back to my country,
I'm not going to talk about it.
So you know,
I'll keep your secret.
You know what they all did?
They I got a farmer's got borderline standing ovation.
All right?
Everything doesn't need to blow up,
all right?
I don't need to turn every fucking restaurant into fucking Kim Kardashians
greased up ass yo with bloke to in a day
dumbest fucking thing ever broke the internet.
And then every fucking Douche that's out there taking selfies has to somehow
squeeze,
broke the Internet into their fucking conversation.
I fucking hate that.
I Hate Internet,
uh,
terminology.
I hate the joke structure.
You know the said no one ever or the uh,
you know,
now it's like you have like a picture and you're like,
Dad,
look on your face when your boss says you don't have to come in Friday.
That fucking,
you know,
insert picture here.
So you don't even have to be like a joke writer.
So dude,
with all due respect with your waving of the fucking American flag,
all right,
here's the deal.
If you'd get in the fucking job done,
all right,
if you get in the fucking job done and everybody in the local town knows you the
shit,
you got to stay in business,
you don't need me to fucking hypey thing and then ruin it like the food network
does.
And speaking of which to,
they'd fucking guy there with his bleach.
Blonde hair is sunburned face guy Fieri driving all around.
I'm telling you that fucking guy,
I,
I've gone to some of the places he's,
they hit or miss.
They hit a miss.
That guy's been on the air for like 10 years.
He's out of places to go to.
Not to mention he never goes to drive ins.
Okay.
He occasionally goes into diners.
He never goes into a dive that basically diners,
but he needed the magic of three.
Um,
anyways,
so no,
I'm not doing that.
Okay.
If you know how to make a fucking brisket,
the Goddamn word is going to be out.
All right.
The word's going to get out.
You don't need me to do it.
And uh,
ruined,
ruined the fucking place.
Jesus Christ.
Yelp.
What kind of a fucking moron goes on to Yelp?
It just takes the,
all these fucking people.
You have no idea what they're fucking axes to grind.
I think that there's like a certain level of client that you have to be to even
post a review on Yelp.
Not to mention there's so many cuts on Yelp that this restaurants that have sat
in.
Okay.
And I said,
hey,
I really enjoyed that.
That was delicious.
And they go,
thank you.
Can you please go on Yelp and write a good review?
Cause there's just so many feelings.
They have a little bit of power now and I'm going to fucking furrow my brow.
Have you noticed that ship?
All you need to know about Yelp is just looking at actual critics that get paid
to be critics.
When was the last time you saw him review any fucking movie?
Any fucking movie at all?
In wire to wire.
They said that they enjoyed it.
They never do.
They always have to be country.
They always have to pick out something that they didn't fucking like.
Okay.
All right.
And then what else?
Then you'll see the worst fucking movie ever and they have quotes going.
Outrageous,
hilarious,
a laugh riot and all that is his critics that want to get paid.
So they got to get their name out there,
so then they'll fucking lie to you and say there's some piece of shit is
actually good.
So fuck you.
Fuck Yelp in Fuck Rambo two.
All right.
I'm not,
I'm not out in those places.
All right,
there we go.
I don't know about Fuck Rambo two.
Okay.
Checkout dark city.
Oh,
hey Billy Scifi.
Billy Skywalker.
All right,
I thought that was somebody signing that.
Um,
okay.
The fuck is with all these goddamn Jesus.
[inaudible] here we go.
It's starting.
Um,
oh well shit,
I ain't,
did you see my email?
Did you kick out the hotel options side five,
Billy Skywalker checkout dark city.
I asked last week,
uh,
you know,
I really enjoyed,
um,
a moon with Sam Rockwell and I didn't realize the director was David Bowie's
son,
which of course I don't have his fucking name here right now.
I'm the worst.
Um,
so I said,
what is some other Scifi movies?
I'd love to check them out.
And somebody says,
uh,
Billy Skywalker checkout dark city.
It's not action packed,
but like moon,
you got to see it.
It's shot beautifully intense is fuck,
it's on Hbo Right now.
Don't delay.
Also,
if you haven't seen blade runner recently,
give it a rewatch.
Um,
your fellow pilot,
Harrison Ford,
delivers a really underrated performance.
Make sure you watch the director's cut.
It's the only way it'll make sense.
Oh Wow.
I got fucking,
Nah,
I gotta check that out.
Um,
oh my God.
What is this?
This seems like a disaster waiting to happen.
Listen to this one kitten for Cleo.
Bill,
have you ever thought of getting a kitten to help calm cleo down?
I can't imagine cleo having a problem with it.
Oh,
I can't.
I imagine it'd be possible for Cleo to eventually become protective of the
kitten,
which would,
could turn into making things worse.
Okay.
So why would I do that?
I'll let you do the research,
but if you had to imagine how it played out,
what do you think would happen?
Um,
I think my dog would eat the cat.
I think she would view it as a threat because she's possessive and I think I
would come home and the dog would be wagging its tail with for around its mouth
and blood on its chin.
And um,
I would find maybe or kitten,
they probably be swallowed whole,
but they might be a fucking pause in my kitchen or something else.
Horrific that I'd have to try and block out.
Okay.
I remember when they taught that grill out how to do sign language.
They get,
they got that thing a pet cat.
I Dunno.
A kitten.
I'm not,
I'm not a big fan of cats.
I totally respect him.
How they live their lives and their anti authority and like,
you know,
the same way you couldn't put me in a leash.
She can't put them on Alicia,
although I know a few people have done it.
But whatever.
I'm just saying generally speaking.
Um,
the only thing I like about cats,
I like watching them sleep in the sun.
Reminds me to take an old man nap every day.
And then I also like how easy it is to discipline him.
You know,
all you do is just give it a nice little smack on that little fucking nose and
then they get it,
you know?
No kidding.
All you have to do is just have to spray water bottle.
Right?
And they're still going to go up on a couch,
but it's just fun to fucking shoot something that doesn't die and you get to
feel that cool feel on a shooting.
Something,
you know,
I dunno.
Is that evil?
Oh,
go fuck yourself.
What do you want from me?
Um,
all right,
let me,
let me read the last little bit of advertising and I'll tell you a cute story
and then that's going to be a fucking week.
What do you think about that?
All right.
Draftkings everybody spring training is underway and that schmuck training and
all.
Anyway,
let me get,
let me get in.
Character
draft kings.com spring training is underway and that can only mean one thing.
Baseball season as almost hair.
And there's never been a better time to check out draft kings.com America's
favorite daily fantasy baseball site where yeah,
could win huge cash prizes every day.
Right there.
Daily fantasy means no season long commitments.
You can dip in and dip out.
No slogging through a long season to collect your winnings.
Just instant cash.
Instant gratification,
right?
It's like watching black guys play chess in the park.
Picking up the pace here.
It's like a new season.
Every time you play,
simply play two pitches and eight positional players.
Stay under the salary cap and you could be on your way to a massive payday.
This actually sounds fun.
In fact,
draft says already crown over a dozen millionaires,
hundreds of thousands of fantasy sports fans.
Just like you have cashed in at draft kings.
Now it's your turn.
Call the action.
Hurry to draft kings.com now and use the Promo code defense to play for free in
the hundred thousand dollar fantasy baseball contest on opening day.
Ah,
what a great way to start the fucking season.
Chance to win a hundred grand.
First place takes home 10 grant.
Wow.
$10,000 use promo gets to worry to win $10,000 whatever.
That's still good.
Use Promo code defense for free entry now@draftkingsdotcomdraftkings.com that's
draft kings.com all right,
legal zoom.
If you were thinking legal zoom,
everybody,
if you were thinking about starting a business,
now's the best time to do it.
It's national starch your business month if he fucking month@legalzoom.com and
it's never been easier to start to build your future.
Legal Zoom provides the support you need for more than 10 years that have helped
them.
1 million business owners just like you if you need legal advice for your
business,
no problem.
Legal Zooms,
not a law firm,
but they've,
they've built a network for trusted attorneys to provide the guidance you need
for your specific situation.
Here's the best part.
During national starch,
Your Business Month,
legal zoom is offering an attorney consultation for only 50 bucks.
Sorry,
I got the hiccups for only $50.
If you are unsure about the best way to start or if you're already run a
business and need some advice,
this offer is for you.
Get legal advice for your business with no further obligation for a low one time
costs.
Go to legal zoom.com today to find out more or attorney consultations are
provided by independent attorneys available in most states.
Get the legal help you need for your business@legalzoom.com enter burpee.
You are are in the referral box to entrust in the referral box to save even more
legalzoom.com Promo Code burr legal help is here.
All right,
there you go.
Well that is your podcast for this week.
What can I say?
The Bruins fighting for their playoff lives.
Um,
I was just talking to a Montreal Fan,
right?
Uh,
ranked four right before this,
uh,
this podcast,
I was doing an interview cause I got a couple of shows coming up this summer in
Montreal that will be announced this Wednesday,
by the way,
this Wednesday.
Um,
oh,
by the way,
I'll let you know what I've got coming up.
Okay.
I have a Gig in.
Um,
let's go to bill [inaudible] dot com everybody,
billboard.com.
If you want to fucking pay back this podcast,
but not spend a dime,
just go to bill bird.com.
Click on the page and click on Amazon and you go to Amazon.
And if you buy something,
they give me a little kickback for driving traffic over there.
That's it.
That's all you got.
Do it doesn't cost you any extra money.
They kicked me a little dough.
Everything's good.
Everything's copacetic.
Is that the right word?
I don't know.
All right.
Here's the deal.
I'm doing two shows,
April 10th at the Fillmore in Miami beach at the Jackie Gleason.
Stay at Jackie Gleason theory.
You know what?
This time I'm actually going to go up there and I'm going to take a look at the,
uh,
I'm going to take a look at the,
Jackie Gleason.
I guess they have his office.
You know,
they still kept it the same.
Um,
I missed that last time.
April 11th.
I'm at Ruth Eckerd Hall and Tampa for two shows.
Uh,
April 18th.
That's when the,
um,
April 18th,
that's when the,
uh,
the southern tour starts.
Um,
we're in Savannah,
Georgia,
and Knoxville,
Tennessee,
Chattanooga,
Memphis,
Tennessee,
Shreveport,
Louisiana.
And then we're in New Orleans.
And then after New Orleans,
do you know what it means to Miss New Orleans?
That's where my baby goals.
Then we pick the tour back up on April 26 and we do Huntsville,
Alabama,
Jackson,
Mississippi,
mope mobile,
Alabama,
Lexington,
Kentucky.
And then we're in Evansville,
Indiana.
And then we go to the fucking Kentucky Derby.
Then next I'm doing the Wilbur run in Boston from a,
what is it?
May 9th.
Two.
Why don't we know what day we're up to at this point?
We're doing like 17 shows at this point.
Yeah.
Jesus,
Cleo,
fucking scratching over there.
June 26th and June 27th,
I am at the Mirage Casino in Las Vegas,
Nevada.
All right.
Anybody out there in Vegas?
I'm going to be out there and,
um,
then whatever,
we're going to have some more shows coming up.
I guess I'm going to have to post that one from Montreal that I'm doing during
the Montreal comedy festival.
I'll be up there and the rumor is the Goddamn comedy jam is going to be coming
up there.
So you guys in Montreal,
my Jess might be able to see me sit in a couple of times dressed as my favorite
drummers from the past,
the future.
And today I'm going to try and do that show as many times as I can,
play as many songs as I can.
It's one of my favorite things to do.
Uh,
Josh,
Adam Meyers show is going to be at the Montreal comedy festival and um,
I probably shouldn't have said that.
That's a little bit of a insight information.
Also,
please visit the all things comedy network,
all things,
comedy.com to check out the biggest and brightest and bestest,
um,
podcast
podcast stars.
Is that,
is that the word that I'm supposed to say?
Anyways,
go to all things,
comedy.com and uh,
just check out all these awesome podcasts we got here.
I tried to different ones every week.
Doug,
Stan,
hope we have,
we got your mom's box are re shifts the uh,
the Burke cast,
Tom Papa,
the Farley brothers.
Uh,
we got everybody here.
Come on,
man.
Tom Rhodes radio writer's block.
Yeah.
Writing.
So fucking small.
I can't even read it here.
Uh,
what is this one?
I'll come when I click on things.
It doesn't work.
Or we got deep shit with Baron von,
another great podcast.
Just check out all those men you can just scroll through.
We got everything.
We got stuff for the men,
the women in the lady.
I was,
I guess the men and the ladies.
All right.
That's the podcast for this week.
Um,
I got a big guest this week for the Thursday podcast.
He's such a big guest that I'm actually waiting to do the third Thursday podcast
on Friday,
Friday uploaded before,
say,
um.
Anyways,
that's the podcast for this week.
Thank you so much for listening.
Go fuck yourselves.
And I will talk to you next I guess Friday.
I'll talk to you on Friday.
All right,
that's it.
See you.
Okay.